à ces motos pompes pour évacuer la lola
quant à elle plus quand la voiture il
passe ici
les lolo il ment yvan ils vont dans les
magasins dans les garages et tout ça
sajoo.fr comme ça
pour nettoyer les moteurs pour évacuer
les lalo
et
selon là quand il est là personne ne
vient ici pour acheter quelque chose
ne pouvons pas travailler normal ils
voient les tableaux est vraiment nous
sommes fatigués
où
ce qui nous préoccupe actuellement c'est
que la vie est trop chère ici au sénégal
vont gueuler prison à en os coiffées
rich et matières premières et ici on le
consomme le journal errements dont il
fut un temps ça on l'a achetée à 14 me
mais actuellement je conseille avec 2000
donc c'est très cher l'huile aussi même
chose ça coûte excessivement cher et il
s'est produit de base là si ça coûte
cher la population souffre vraiment
avec john holmes
[Musique]
chaque jour je reçois des appels
téléphoniques
des gens qui crient au secours parce que
ils n'ont rien à manger c'est pourquoi
l'association aussi viennent en aide ces
familles les le ces familles devenues à
les
deux allaient donnant des sacs de riz de
l'huile de sucre etc tout ce qu'est une
famille a besoin pour se nourrir
voilà
oh